lakers by 24
lakers by 26. anthony davis has 24 and
eric's supposed to
right now needs another timeout an
avalanche here from the lakers in game
one
dominating is short james gets it james
ahead to kuzma but he won't get it off
in time
and that ends a terrific second quarter
for the lakers
a 30-point turnaround they trailed by 13
in that first quarter in game one of
these nba finals lebron james
close to another playoff triple-double
dwight howard got the start did an
excellent job on bam adebayo and davis
has been spectacular this presentation
of the nba finals continues
after this as quickly as it happened
kendrick nunn knocks that one down that
was the
memorial day mass
there's the longtime veteran of the
miami heat indonesia
and when you say miami heat culture
it is udonis hassle we talked about him
a lot
during the conference finals he's 40
years old his 17th year
eric spoelstra just uh absolutely loves
him
as a competitor he doesn't really 23
remaining here in the fourth as the
lakers
set to take game one well this is
straight up bully ball lebron james
against jones jr
and he's scowling
who has been so important wasn't able to
score in this game